Can I Hebrew speaker understand an
Arabic speaker?
Well,
the short answer is no.
The long answer is Kinda sorta maybe,
but not really.
No.
The question,
one of the day is how similar our Hebrew
and Arabic as someone who has studied
both languages,
I get asked this question by quite a few
people.
Um,
and it's a good question.
It makes me think because I'm not quite
sure,
but I'll give you my best answer.
Basically Hebrew and Arabic are very
closely related languages and if you
study both,
that will become very apparent.
You'll see tons of similarities and if
you know one well already,
that will help you learn the other much
more easily,
but at the same time they are not
mutually comprehensible.
That means,
uh,
you,
if you speak one and not the other,
that you won't be able to communicate
with someone who speaks the other
language.
So they're not,
you can't,
you can't communicate as though they're
the same language and won't work.
Okay.
So let's talk about some things that are
kind of similar and I'll throw in some
differences as I go.
And then I'll talk about how there are
not really useful as a communication
tool with each other.
Okay.
So they're similar because of the verbal
system and in terms of how you create
words in the language.
So in both Hebrew and Arabic,
they have a system of roots.
Now those roots are usually three
consonant letters and you take those
three consonant letters and you put them
into kind of templates that help you
create a word.
So the templates are patterns.
They're like,
um,
a set of,
of a combination of vowels and ethics is
that could be a prefix or suffix or even
an in fix inside the word.
So let's take a three letter root and
I'll give you an example.
In Hebrew,
you've got the root ca to va,
that's Katie v.
If you recognize it,
and in Arabic you've got to book Katie,
be romanized it already.
You can see there's a similarity.
That route is almost the same.
The book and the va are different,
but low sounds are equivalent.
So if you put them into the templates,
you can change it.
Let's use a verb conjugation template in
the past tense.
This is the simplest structure in both
languages.
So in Hebrew,
if you say,
I wrote,
you would say cut off d in Arabic you
would say the top two or in a dialect
maybe cut up in Hebrew for the second
person,
masculine for you,
you would say a cutoff in Arabic.
Cut Up top.
So you can see that's quite similar for
the Feminine Second Person Singular in
Hebrew,
you would say cutoff in Arabic,
you would say.
Okay,
so you could see there there's a
similarity here in the way that you put
the roots into these templates to
conjugate the verbs and you can see that
the conjugations are kind of similar.
Uh,
the templates are kind of similar but
they're not exactly the same.
And there could be confusion like,
um,
for uh,
for the one I said for a in Hebrew,
it's cutoff date that I wrote,
but in Arabic means you wrote,
it's when spoken to a female.
So you can see there could be a
confusion there and you might
misunderstand.
I think they're talking about someone
else.
I'm right.
But she could see that same kind of
system and that that kind of system of
templates is used to create nouns to
create adjectives,
all kinds of words,
just the templates are different and
have different affixes attached to them
and different vowels.
So that's one thing is that system of
roots and templates,
it's the same in both.
So if you learn that once for one
language,
it's just getting that concept down
really helps you with the second
language that uses that same system
because it's a bit mind bending at first
to adjust to that route and template
system.
Another way that there are similar is in
terms of just a lot of vocabulary,
you already saw that that one route,
the cut,
the cut the book.
So there's a lot of vocabulary that's
the same.
It's not the majority of words though.
It's not like 80 percent or something
like that.
It's,
I would,
I don't know the exact percentage.
I would guess that it's about a third
that's just off the top of my head from
my studying experience.
A third,
uh,
some of the words are very similar or
almost the same.
And some are,
some are clearly related,
if you examine the words,
but you might not notice that just from
hearing them because the phonology of
the languages has become different due
to the languages history.
It's similar in French and Italian,
French and Italian.
If you read two sentences,
um,
equivalent centers,
this side by side,
you can look at them and you can say,
oh,
this word must be the same as this word.
This one must be the same as this one
because the words look kind of similar.
They sound different and the spelling is
different.
But you can look at them and see that
they're the same.
They have the same meaning because they
look similar.
Uh,
so there are a lot of words like that,
like they're the kind of cognates,
but they're slightly different.
Um,
so I'll give you some examples of both
types.
Like the ones that are very similar,
a yad in Hebrew and Arabic,
that means hand dumb in Hebrew and
Arabic.
That means blood,
right?
Um,
there's a lot of words that are similar
like that.
The,
almost the same like that.
Some that you can figure out quite
easily with the pronouns,
like I is an the in Hebrew or in Arabic
or in Hebrew,
you for a man as a ta in Arabic gets
untaught,
right?
He is who in Hebrew,
it's in Arabic,
right?
Um,
and that might,
might depend on the dialect to,
in Arabic is different in from country
to country.
Another one kitchen in Hebrew Mitzvah
and in Arabic gets macbook.
So pretty close.
Just one vowel changes in the Arabic
one,
uh,
some that are a little bit more
different,
but you can see the similarity,
especially if you know the function or
meaning of the word,
like this one to you or for you in
Hebrew is the hot.
But in Arabic it's lack.
So if you look at the vowels,
sorry,
if you look at the consonants you can
see,
okay,
l k versus l,
C h,
those might be the same,
right?
Of in Hebrew is father Abba in Arabic.
So again,
you see that be in the V,
another one,
Ben,
his son in Hebrew Eban his son in
Arabic.
So if you just look at the consonants
that be in the end,
you can say,
oh,
those are related.
Another one,
rush,
rush means head in Hebrew,
and last,
last means head in Arabic.
So that's in rush.
Those are clearly related.
Another one,
tongue in Hebrew,
lashawn in Arabic.
Listen,
the sun,
so the sun and the show,
maybe there's a change there.
And also the,
the old became an r sound.
So there's some shifts in the sounds
going on.
Dog in Hebrew is Kelly in Arabic,
it's called.
So you can see there are a lot of words
that have a similar,
a similar route or if they come from the
same word,
but they've shifted and become
different.
So there's a lot of words like that that
you wouldn't necessarily understand when
you hear them.
And other one,
that's this,
uh,
there are some words that are the same,
but they have a different meaning like a
Medina or Medina.
In Hebrew,
Medina is state like Israel,
the state of Israel.
But in Arabic Medina means a city.
So they're both political entities.
There is a connection in the meaning,
but it's not exactly the same,
meaning the meaning has become different
and they're also a lot of words that are
just different entirely.
For whatever reason.
It's always kind of strange to discover
words that are exactly the same in
Hebrew and Arabic.
And then the next word in the sentence
is entirely different and you've never
seen it before.
So like why did this one become the same
in both languages,
but this one is different.
What?
So it makes it kind of interesting.
I don't always know.
You usually don't know the answer,
but yeah.
Anyway,
there's a lot of different vocabulary so
you can see that there are quite related
and there's a lot of crossover but you
won't understand one just by learning
the other.
Right.
It will help you learn the other.
If you make the effort though and if you
take what you know and try to apply it
to the other language.
Well learning.
So let me give you an example of when I
first went to Egypt in 1997.
I went there after having studied Hebrew
for a couple of years already and I was
visiting Israel and I went to Egypt to,
so I tried to use my Hebrew and apply it
to Arabic because I only knew a little
bit of Arabic.
I didn't know enough to really to have a
conversation or whatever.
So I would try to use my very simple
Arabic and insert Hebrew words into it.
And I knew the difference in phonology,
so I would kind of shift in Arab buys my
pronunciation of the Hebrew words.
And I was surprised by how often people
understood me and the people didn't
speak Hebrew.
They weren't seen bruce speakers,
but they understood,
I guess they could,
they could hear the word and think of an
equivalent or similar sounding word in
Arabic or they could cure the root and
maybe that route was used in a different
word in there,
Arabic dialect or whatever.
Uh,
so they could figure out what I was
saying a lot of the time.
And they looked at me strangely.
They thought maybe I was a Weirdo or I
remember they often asked me if I was
from Lebanon,
so maybe they thought that my bizarre
Arabic pigeon language was Lebanese
Arabic.
That seemed to be something like that.
They kept asking me if I was from
Lebanon.
Uh,
it happened like that in Jordan too.
I remember when I was in Jordan the same
year,
um,
that I,
I managed to use some Hebrew words in
situations where I was surprised that it
went across.
So they understood a lot of my Hebrew
words when I era buys them.
So that's just an example of how the
language has crossover and you,
you can apply one to the other,
but they're generally not mutually
comprehensible.
You have to make the effort to shift it
to change that knowledge into the other
language.
So that's why there are two different
languages,
not dialects of the same language.
All right.
So that's,
that's what I wanted to share with you.
Just my experience with how similar they
are,
give you some similarities,
differences,
and hope you understand a little bit
better than before.
All right.
Thank you for listening.
Good Nights.